on va passer une petite interview ivana
très sympathique c'est un petit jeu un
espace sans importance ça s'appelle
l'interview alerte aux roses
bien calé ivana trump votre première
pensée quand vous vous trouvez en face
d'un homme séduisant qui menace les on a
envie de le tenir dans ses bras
et puis le troisième je vais partir il
est ravi de la glace et on envie de te
tenir dans ses bras bon voilà ça vous
donne une idée à peu près quel est pour
vous le quel est pour vous il va naître
un italien s'est elle a dit que j'ai une
dame attention je vais pas dire moi
aussi qu'elle est calé pour vous il va
naître un peu le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte
à la place on sait jamais ce qui va se
passer après olalala
des essais 6 bookings c'est un cas et le
regarde et ses toits qu'elle adore
surtout avec les italiens accord sirois
la consultation c'est est ce que vous
préférez draguer ou vous faire draguer
on s'est toujours l'homme qui donne
droit qu'est le sida
tout ça c'est alors de venir à moi c'est
ça qui leur plaît aux hommes il aime
travailler pour venir vous chercher
est ce que vous préférez largué vous
faire larguer na na li non c'est moi qui
l'ait qui a c'est vous qui le dites et
ça il faut vous draguer mais après c'est
vous qui quittent et si les passagers
savaient pas gentil a tant pis s vous
préféré embrasser ou qu on vous embrasse
j'aime bien les embrasser les hommes moi
ça me gêne pas c'est eux qui m'embrasse
mais j'aime bien basse et j'ai changé
les choses
l'âge fait des blondes jeunesse les
jours là bien alors vraiment des
problèmes je vais avoir des ennuis
est-ce que no problemo ivana trump est
ce que vous conservez un fantasmes
inavouables of race bien sûr et je ne
t'ai pas l'admettre mais pas me
confesser est ce que vous croyez que et
ses fantasmes
eh bien il reste on est c'est à dire des
vous souvent on essaie de lévis vous
essayez pas de vivre tous vos fantasmes
n'en vous vous trouvez ça plus sexy de
les garder en vous plutôt que de les
vivre juste les deux à gérer deux
cahiers les deux dernières questions il
va naître un pack war connaissez-vous la
passion qui s'est à son usine
d'abord ça dépend de la personne si on
parle d'une véritable relation bien sûr
je crois que ce sont des signes comme
tout être un peu moins de faire la mort
au lieu de le faire tous les jours on le
fait tous les deux jours ou bien les
vols entre moyens il est allemand a tout
d'un coup on vous voyez votre homme qui
se teint les cheveux qui se fait couper
les cheveux
j'ai fait des choses différentes de ce
qui fait d'habitude j'habite in qui font
qu'on sait qu'un homme à une liaison par
exemple par exemple il rentre tard à la
maison
bon c'est pas ce qui m'est arrivé à moi
vous êtes de bons conseils merci merci
la france